- I will never name my kid Tiffany.
Every time I see a kid named Tiffany,
I'll be like, "Be quiet, Tiffany!
"Be quiet, Tiffany!"
- [Voiceover] I religiously
watched America's Next Top Model
until cycle 13, I believe.
- [Voiceover] I mean, I haven't watched it
in a really long time, to be honest.
I'm only 23.
We've had almost as many seasons
as I've had years on this earth.
That's amazing, Tyra.
- I remember when I first discovered
America's Next Top Model.
I thought it was such
a janky-looking show,
because, you know, it
was the first season.
But then, like, I just saw it like grow
into this cultural phenomenon.
- My favorite model
definitely had to be Jade,
because she was a boss-ass
bitch with no filter.
And no one will ever
forget when she's like,
"This is not America's
Next Top Best Friend,"
and she, like, went to the
ANTM and, like, pointed at it.
- I'm still resentful that Kim
from season five didn't win,
Kim the lesbian.
- Little gay Taylor was like, "Oh, man.
"There are models that
are gay in this world?
"Like, I'm gonna find
one of those as a wife."
- Janice Dickinson was the best thing
that ever graced the
television screen on that show.
- She kept it so real, and
even though I didn't agree
with a lot of the things that she said,
she kept it, like, super real.
Like, she didn't put up with anybody,
including Tyra's bullshit.
- Is Miss J still on the show?
Was Miss J there til the end?
I hope so.
- Also, can I talk about NIgel?
Hello?
Like, so fine.
- And then, when Shandi
cheated on her boyfriend,
that was like some real world shit.
- I'm sorry, but like, girl,
you're on national television.
What were you doing?
- Some granola bars went missing,
and then,
and then another girl thought
that some other chick had,
Nicole, who ended up winning,
had stolen her granola bars.
And so she went and dumped
Nicole's energy drinks
in the sink.
And it ended up being the
whole big drama of the season
was over granola and energy drinks.
- The Tiffany episode.
When Tiffany didn't make the cut,
and she wasn't quite teared up enough.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, be quiet, Tiffany!
Best moment.
- I honestly don't remember anything else.
- We were rooting for you.
Like, we were all rooting for you.
And she was just like, the most
upset you've ever seen her.
We were rooting for her.
She wasn't wrong.
- RIP, ANTM.
Like, I'm gonna miss you.
- You changed the game.
Never before was there a
modeling show like this.
- We are sad to see you go.
But we gotta pull the plug on
life support at some point.
- I honestly thought that you
ended, like, five years ago.
But goodbye.
- [Voiceover] Tyra, we'll miss you.
But I'm sure we'll see you again soon.
- [Voiceover] Tyra will never leave us.